[Musik]
die ein völlig zerstörtes auto ich
schaue da einmal rein das passiert wenn
man hier eine bank bekommt das auto
komplett zerstören
[Musik]
dass sie für mich aus wie ein
fitnessstudio was was es auch war war
dort die sportgeräte noch firmen zeit
jetzt lasse hier
[Musik]
also hier wo ich bin und wo ist immer
noch raus das ist natürlich ein weites
stück entfernt von dem tv klassischen
distanz wir sehen wir wenn wir einmal
durch hinter den bäumen da schimmert der
tv tower und bringt die rakete rein 1
aber die sieht
störung von bluetooth gps und wir
schauen wir einmal reif sei hier haben
menschen in einer freien und
jetzt das land in trümmern für mich
schon ein symbol dafür dass wir in
dieser stadt passiert
[Musik]
zwei männer die diese stadt verteidigung
wollen sind vitali und wladimir
klitschko und die beiden sind jetzt bei
uns
ja witali und wladimir deutschland
schaut auf euch in diesen stunden
deutschland schaut auf die ukraine auf
alle menschen die angst haben vor den
raketen die hier einschlagen in diesen
stunden in diesen tagen vitali ich war
heute am tv turm unter den fünf
zivilisten ums leben gekommen
wie dramatisch ist die lage in montargis
wurde sind das wollte keiner weiß
bescheid die jede sekunde kann eine
brücke bringt
genau das gleiche
das war eine symbolisch im fernsehen tun
das ist eine bei base und o2
und da ist es passiert
10.000 menschen geworden und genau das
gleiche budget in diesem ersten auch
symbolisch die platz
getroffen dieser platz wurde revision
gebäude
auch wo es aber weil er jetzt
und
wir diesen ok musst du mir bleibt kurz
da gerade mal ein telefonat vitali wie
dramatisch ist die lage in tier momentan
ist wir sehen sie sehen noch mehr und
mehr betten 20 bomben- und wgz bank und
vom
osten durch eine durch die halb
marschiert eine riesige ballone um zug
bestellen ist auch stark und gut und
richtig ja nie der hauptstadt haben
wir kommen ganz andere vision dass wir
werden unser auch stadt und keine geben
ich hab euch jetzt viele experten
gesprochen ja keiner weiß bescheid weiß
die sich entwickeln weil die ganze
infrastrukturen warm wird leute wie sie
befürchtet
millionen arbeitslos
das ist eine riesige brille mich bei
unserem fest begann bevor wir gleich
über einem jahr sprechen noch eine frage
zur versorgung kaum noch genügend
medikamente rein genügend lebensmittel
gibt es etwas was deutschland tun müsste
was europa tun müsst in dieser stunde
wir brauchen noch viel mehr brauchen
schusswesten
was gedreht gewinnt wäre hilfe haben mit
herz schon gesprochen mit billy revision
ich sage auf jeden fall beschreibt hier
haben wir jetzt haben wir genug für
produkte lebensmittel aber denk ich mal
das müssen wir noch zusätzlich bekommen
weil diese sind so glaube ich die länge
der alles warum aber gibt es noch nicht
eigentlich erst richtig stand er wisse
nicht aber das ist wie das ist gewohnt
gut in einem kessel zu 900 gäste
vladimir berlin ja wir müssen das
einfach unseren zuschauern erklären an
der historische ort dramatischer ort
holocaust gedenkens nehmen uns nochmal
mit du bist jemand der sich da sehr
engagiert das ist da wo die raketen
eingeschlagen in der nähe des tv tipps
was ist dort genau passiert
gibt es hineingeschlagen
82 jahren sind die kugel angeschlagen so
zu sagen es war wohl kostet googles so
genannt ist das
rund 1000 menschen sind
heute nach 82 jahren schon wieder bei
gleicher stelle sterben menschen von der
musik weiter
ich kann es kaum fassen wie absurd diese
welle geworden ist vor allem nicht die
welt sondern die politik und russland
gut dass man killt die zivilisten
um irgendwelche wünsche zu erfüllen und
gleichzeitig es geht letztendlich um
was kreatives was passiert in der
ukraine ist desto und die sieht die
satzung über die saßen sie zerstören
wird noch sehr sehr sehr
dass ich so schnell will das land sich
nicht erholt auch nach dem krieg
weil er ist blöd zu sagen
das kriegst du sprichst du hast heute
gesagt die menschen aufgefordert dass
sie die stadt verteidigen sollen aber
wie kann die menschen dass wenn man
diese raketen sieht die von island
benutzt werden putins raketen die auch
schon in syrien eingesetzt wir haben das
sind relativ gesehen bist du besorgt
dass die waffen hier auch in kiew
eingesetzt werden und wie können die
menschen hat ihre stadt verteidigen war
hörte sind vitali denn machen
wir haben danke an lindenberg hat uns
die schicke beteiligungs waffen und wir
haben schon ihren daten bekommen wir
mehr und mehr die partie gelaufen
deswegen
oder handy hoch oder willi charakter zu
zeigen und unsere vorstellungen was ist
dein gefühl was will wladimir putin du
sagst die hauptstadt als haben wir aber
heute nachrichten bekommen dass es
spekulationen gibt dass ausgerechnet
herr janukowytsch wieder eingesetzt
werden könnte als präsident putin
gewinnen sollte das ist der mann gegen
den du und lade mir und viele
hunderttausend auf dem majdan stand und
demonstriert haben was macht das mit dir
allein
durch strompreise wären es sogar gibt
sehr viele
glauben kann so etwas macht weil er
braucht
ein
abhängig und janukowitsch wäre eine
solche marionette
aber einmal als präsident oder jemand
bei uns regieren das muss autorität habe
er heute muss er anerkennen
respektieren wir mal
wie man hat das gefühl so grausam dieser
krieg ist soviel opfer ist gibt dass es
im land dafür sorgt dass der
zusammenhalt noch stärker wie in der
ukraine und der patriotismus und der
wille dieses land auch zu verteidigen
wie nimmst du das war ich bin stolz auf
mich
ich bin stolz seine gründe zu sein ich
glaube
jetzt die
ganze welt ukraine
weil das ist massiv und der ukraine aber
gleichzeitig sagt die welt auch wir
schicken euch waffen wir schicken euch
hilfe aber militärisch seid ihr auf euch
allein gestellt
bestimmt das geschehen ja
es gibt gewalt sich suding
letztendlich ist das zuhause
wo die eltern
begraben sehen in den schule gehen nur
leider sind auch kinder wenn die
zivilisten dem sinne sind schon gekippt
gehören das partner gruppen in der stadt
sein sollen scharfschützen der stadt
sein sollen russische soldaten in der
stadt band 9 ich muss diese frage jedes
mal stellen mit ali und wladimir wie
schützt ihr euch
ich würde nicht bezahlen wie
um bestimmte runde
riesch musste ich jetzt sehr sehr viel
arbeit und wenig zeit zu sparen weil wir
mussten so viele organisieren
arrangieren dass es die bauen bei
diktaten jetzt immer mehr also um klima-
umwelt- barrikaden gebaut
das ist
[Musik]
auch
ein blatt wird eine heizung gehäuse
draufsteht ist ziemlich
priester die versorgung ich habe gesehen
in einigen supermärkten fehlt es schon
an bestimmten motto funktioniert das
noch jetzt immer mehr so wichtig ist
gibt deswegen
schnell zu bringen bestimmt ist noch
schwierig aber wer
zu spenden und eine bestimmte produkte
werbung zu schicken wir wissen nicht wie
lange es hier person wird wärmen und das
wegen deswegen wir brauchen gestoßen und
wollte wohl in
der
planie mir rechnet ihr rechnest du mit
einem monatelangen häuserkampf und kehrt
mit rechnet man muss ausdauer wie lange
wird es dann darum weiß keine ausdauer
schlägt die glas verlieren kommt schnell
deswegen
hoffen das quorum
eventualität bereit seien aber denke ich
mal die diskussion ist nicht einfach das
dauert denkt ihr dass wladimir putin in
irgendeiner art von verhandlungen gehen
kann oder ist er so unterwegs dass er
sagen wird er
dafür 1 aleppo in syrien bombardierte
putin brauch ein sieg und mit
ca
und deswegen jetzt die medien
instrumenten das gab mir in seine hände
das ist ein krieg für
online der ist mehrheiten würde sagen ja
das ist interessant wir bestätigen
unsere interesse wie befreiend
polizisten faschisten nationalisten
und das land und die propaganda der
propaganda und deswegen ist noch alles
menschen man muss auch erklären
und jede muss richtig begreifen das ist
ein kampf sogar richtig satten aber ich
berichte gesehen und da regiert werden
wir sehen wie zivilisten grund und
stoppen gbp zurück nach hause da gab es
die berühmten bilder und in der ukraine
und panzer einfuhren und dann die
soldaten fried nicht sozusagen zur
umkehr bewogen
heute wohl nicht reinlassen immer
und
deswegen deswegen das ist diejenige
bombach keine wie sie gekämpft nicht
begegnen sie liest man rechnet ihr mit
dem angriff wien aktiv mit einem
dauerfeuer bekehrt das produziert was
macht ihr dann geht ihr dann den bunker
gibt traditionell gehen aber
inszenieren
arbeiten
unsere stars schützen wladimir du bist
auch international mit vielen in kontakt
was die frage angeht wie proteinen auf
putin druck gemacht werden kann was muss
aus deiner sicht noch passieren was kann
deutschland tun was kann die welt tun
ist genug passiert gibt es da ein
umschwung in russland dadurch dass die
wirtschaftssanktionen jetzt tatsächlich
lust und es gibt natürlich was die
information aber was die sanktion
auch wenn wir schon bis nicht gesprochen
hat dann spielt man abschalten
aber vielleicht doch lassen also wünsche
und dann wohl sondern kann nicht
schwanger sein und
es geht so musizieren im sportlichen
bereich sowie das fifa uefa und
sie also intensiver libysche komitee
gemacht mit den teams mannschaften dass
sie mich partizipiere können also jede
jede art und weise
funktion hat sanktion
hoffentlich wie sie klingt krieg zu
schnell deswegen
kein ende bleibt möglich so sagen dass
es
stoppt kommunizieren oder geschäfte
machen es habe für russland dieses geld
bekommt
europäische hier
jedes jahr statt investieren in seine
wirtschaft
investieren in seine arme um wirkung
sehen sie in indurain und deswegen
keine kooperation
also muss so ein mann in deutschland
sehr bekannt altkanzler gerhard schröder
er hat immer noch nicht deine ämter
abgegeben will weiter an jetzt gazprom
und rosneft arbeiten was macht das mit
euch ihr kennt ihn auch von früheren
zeiten nämlich ein langer umgekehrt was
macht es mich
dass ich finde ich finde es eine
grausamkeit ich habe bereits gefordert
in verschiedenen kommentaren dass man
ihm alles wegnehmen müsste was die
steuerzahler noch brutal
ist immer noch dort wo es
weil es nicht genügend durchsetzung
gehabt der politik aus meiner sicht was
sollen gedanken halten
ich hoffe es wird was getan
er sollte sanktioniert werden aus meiner
sicht wissen
wenn die welt nicht zusammen und gegen
diesen russischen aggression gegen die
creme gerade herrscht im ganzen club
ganz so lang
die verlegung und
deswegen will zusammen
es ist desto ist ein krieg zu führen
deswegen bitte
gemeinsame tester nur gemeinsam
gemeinsam werden wir
ganz schön vitali und wladimir klitschko
ich kann nur sagen dass ich alles alles
gute wünsche auch in den nächsten
stunden und die nächsten tage eines kann
ich versprechen wie bei bild bleiben
hier berichten weiter und berichten
weiter was hier auf den straßen passiert
und wie es weitergeht und damit zurück
zu euch zu anderen thomas